[Música]
yo bailo envuelve a la casa blanca pero
esta vez como inquilino el presidente
electo que se pronunció desde wilmington
delaware centró su mensaje en unir a
eeuu y acabar con la retórica agresiva
su fórmula vicepresidencial kamala
harris primera mujer en la historia
electa para este cargo le dijo a las
mujeres niños y minorías que ella
representa un país que es la tierra de
las posibilidades
el triunfo lleno de euforia a los
partidarios de bailén convencidos de que
la elección abre una nueva era todo lo
contrario a los seguidores del
presidente trump que protestan apoyando
las falsas acusaciones de su líder que
afirma que le robaron la elección
trump jugaba golf cuando se hizo el
anuncio y se reporta que no ha llamado
al declarado vencedor a reconocer su
victoria como es tradicional
luís arce se posesiona en las próximas
horas como el nuevo presidente de
bolivia donarse el movimiento al
socialismo vuelve al poder y el ex
presidente evo morales regresa a bolivia
con protestas pero sin éxito la
oposición intentó frenar la investidura
tenemos reporte desde la paz
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros y bienvenidos a esta
actualización de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez el mundo
amanece con los ojos puestos en joe
biden que será el nuevo inquilino de la
casa blanca en su discurso tras ser
declarado el presidente número 46 de
eeuu hizo reiterados llamados a la
unidad y a sanar las heridas dejadas por
la polarización se mostró decidido a
trabajar desde ya en temas como la
pandemia de kobe 19 el racismo y el
cambio climático su vicepresidenta
kamala harris primera mujer y primera
afroamericana electa en el cargo llamó a
romper las barreras que dividen al país
andrés meza muñoz tiene los detalles
joe biden volverá a la casa blanca esta
vez como inquilino tras ser electo
presidente de eeuu ante un público
eufórico el líder demócrata presentó su
discurso de victoria tras unas
elecciones que pusieron en vilo al país
durante cuatro días el pueblo de esa
nación ha hablado
ellos nos entregaron un mensaje una
victoria clara hemos ganado con la mayor
cantidad de votos troche que alguna vez
votada del sur en la historia del país
74 millones
bardem se refirió a las infundadas
acusaciones de fraude por parte del
presidente de donald trump y sus
seguidores y pidió reconciliación es
momento de pasar a un lado la retórica
agresiva bajar la temperatura vernos el
uno al otro escucharnos el uno al otro
de nuevo y para lograr progreso debemos
dejar de detener trata de nuestros
oponentes como nuestros enemigos ellos
no son nuestros enemigos son
estadounidenses entre los pilares de su
agenda baiden resaltó la lucha contra el
kobe 19 el cambio climático y el racismo
el líder demócrata también halagó a su
compañera de fórmula
quien se convirtió en la primera mujer
en llegar a la vicepresidencia de
estados unidos además de ser afro y
tener descendencia india
baby the first mensajes humanos
aunque sean la primera mujer en este
cargo no será la última
[Aplausos]
watson porque cada niña que está viendo
esto podrá ver que este es un país de
posibilidades aunque aún faltan más de
dos meses para su posición el equipo
vaivén harris ya anunció sus planes para
poner su agenda en marcha pero el
proceso de transición amenaza con
complicarse teniendo un presidente
saliente que todavía no contempla dejar
la casa blanca
vamos a hablar con nuestra corresponsal
mamen sala que se encuentra en la ciudad
de filadelfia en pensilvania mamen
buenos dias joe biden su partido y sus
partidarios afirman que están haciendo
historia que hay de cierto en esto
sin muy buenos días valentina pues así
es el que fue vicepresidente con barack
obama durante 8 años está haciendo
historia una vez más porque joe biden ya
lo había hecho anteriormente no
solamente ha sido el candidato a la
presidencia más votado con más de 74
millones de votos también se convirtió
en el senador más joven cuando ganó esa
posición en el senado de delaware además
joe biden tiene una extensa trayectoria
política en este país ha sido dos veces
candidato a unas primarias demócratas y
nunca había conseguido enfrentarse a su
contrincante republicano hasta ahora la
tercera parece que ha ido la velocidad y
lo he hecho muy bien y además wyden es
el segundo presidente católico en este
país pero nada de esto ha hecho que el
electo presidente haya olvidado sus
orígenes humildes aquí en una ciudad de
scranton en el estado de pensilvania
precisamente ese estado que le dio los
20 votos electorales para llegar a la
casa blanca momento
kamala harris se considera una clave
para que el demócrata haya
a la presidencia y se pronunció a favor
de romper barreras que más se puede
resaltar de su discurso
y valentina kamala harris que también ha
hecho historia como decía es la primera
mujer que ha llegado a la
vicepresidencia y primera mujer además
afroamericana y de descendencia india
hizo precisamente hincapié en esto en
que ella había habría sido la primera ha
sido la primera mujer en llegar a la
vicepresidencia pero va a luchar para
que no sea la última recordó también a
su madre que llegó a este país como una
inmigrante que nunca imaginó que su hija
pudiera llegar a convertirse en la
vicepresidenta de este país pero este es
un país de posibilidades de
oportunidades y precisamente ha tenido
también un mensaje para niños y niñas
sin importar el género diciéndoles que
deben soñar con ambición liderar con
condición y nivel en ellos aquellos ver
en ellos aquello que otros no pueden ver
también dio las gracias a los
estadounidenses porque en un momento en
el que parecía peligrar la democracia
los estadounidenses salieron a la calle
a votar a pesar de la situación difícil
en la que nos encontramos esa situación
kamala cerro su discurso diciendo que
espera ser tan buena vicepresidenta como
lo fue joe biden para barack obama leal
preparada y honesta pero me muchas
gracias por todos estos detalles más
adelante ampliaremos toda la información
miles de seguidores del ahora presidente
electo se tomaron las calles en varias
ciudades de eeuu celebraron la victoria
y aseguraron que bailen traerá el cambio
que le urge al país el triunfo del nuevo
inquilino de la casa blanca causó enojo
e indignación entre la campaña del
presidente trump y sus fieles seguidores
que sin pruebas defienden que les
robaron la elección
trump jugaba golf en esos momentos y no
se reporta que haya llamado al declarado
vencedor como marca la tradición veamos
más detalles en el informe de matías a
raíz
un ambiente de celebración
luego de que varios medios de
comunicación y la agencia de noticias ap
dieran como ganador a joe biden
[Aplausos]
y este es uno de los grandes días en la
historia de eeuu
sabes realmente hemos probado que la
democracia ha ganado realmente que gran
día para el mundo y para todas las
personas de este país
un escenario similar se registró en
pensilvania el estado que le abrió la
puerta de la oficina oval al demócrata
estamos muy emocionadas estamos muy
emocionadas eeuu hablo y hemos ganado
cada voto con todo creemos en nuestros
corazones que bailen es lo mejor para
eeuu
[Aplausos]
paren el robo es la consigna que mueve
entre los partidarios del presidente de
trump las protestas en apoyo al
mandatario incrementaron cuando el
conteo en pensilvania le dio a bailén la
victoria
vimos un intento de golpe de estado en
nuestro país nos están quitando la
libertad y nos está quitando la gente
que no le gusta eeuu y están
atrincherados en lo que se llama el
estado profundo
arizona carolina del norte y georgia
las protestas se concentran en los
estados donde sigue el conteo no se han
reportado hechos de violencia pero si el
presidente se sigue negando a aceptar el
resultado la indignación de sus
partidarios puede crecer
decenas de líderes mundiales felicitaron
a joe biden ya kamala harris por su
victoria en las elecciones de eeuu ha
abiertos partidarios de trump como los
primeros ministros británico o de israel
enviaron sus felicitaciones enemigos de
trump como el gobierno de irán y los
líderes palestinos señalaron que esta es
la oportunidad de enmendar los errores
de la actual administración los líderes
de rusia china turquía brasil y méxico-
optaron por el silencio o la espera
el mundo le dio la bienvenida al nuevo
presidente electo de eeuu en américa las
felicitaciones llegaron por parte de los
mandatarios desde canadá hasta chile e
incluso venezuela sumida en prolongadas
tensiones con washington venezuela la
patria del libertador simón bolívar
siempre estará dispuesta al diálogo y al
entendimiento con el pueblo y el
gobierno de los eeuu
el presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro
cercano al presidente camps decidió
guardar silencio así lo reportaron
fuentes cercanas hasta esperar un cuadro
completo de los resultados méxico tuvo
una reacción similar vamos nosotros
terminen
y resolver todos los
queremos ser imprudentes
luego de que los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses anunciaran la victoria
de byd en twitter fue la plataforma
escogida por los líderes mundiales para
enviar sus mensajes los europeos con
quien el presidente truman tenía
disputas en materia comercial y cambio
climático se mostraron deseosos de
trabajar en una agenda conjunta con byd
en la alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo
recortó la promesa de campaña del líder
demócrata sobre traer a eeuu de vuelta
al acuerdo de parís cuya salida se
oficializó esta semana bienvenido de
nuevo eeuu felicitaciones al joe biden y
kamala harris por su elección mientras
estamos a punto de celebrar el quinto
aniversario del acuerdo de parís
esta victoria simboliza nuestra
necesidad de actuar juntos más que nunca
en vista a la emergencia climática
medio-oriente no fue la excepción
pakistán jordania e iraq coincidieron en
la búsqueda de una agenda en común que
permita paz y estabilidad en la región
donde eeuu ha tenido fuerte presencia en
su lucha contra el estado islámico y el
programa nuclear de irán
vamos ahora hasta américa latina' faltan
pocas horas para que luis arce se
posicione como nuevo presidente de
bolivia lo que marca el retorno del
movimiento al socialismo al poder y
permite que el ex mandatario evo morales
que estaba exiliado en argentina vuelva
a su tierra desde la paz nuestra
corresponsal meriva k nos contó sobre
las delegaciones que ya llegaron a la
investidura los retos del nuevo jefe de
estado y las protestas que sin éxito
convocó la oposición para frenar esta
posesión
en bolivia todo está listo para la
posesión del nuevo presidente del país
luis arse y de su vicepresidente david
choquehuanca en las últimas horas han
arribado a bolivia diferentes
delegaciones del exterior entre ellas la
de españa que está presidida por el rey
felipe también están en bolivia tres
jefes de estado el presidente de
argentina alberto fernández el
presidente de paraguay mario abdo
benítez y el presidente de colombia iván
duque por otro lado han llegado hasta la
ciudad de la paz y se han parapetado en
los alrededores de la plaza murillo los
sectores sociales que apoyan al
movimiento al socialismo el partido
ganador de las elecciones porque quieren
garantizar la posesión de luisa se pues
en las últimas horas hubo anuncios de
los opositores de que darían protestas
en contra de los resultados de las
elecciones de hecho en las últimas horas
también hubo algunas manifestaciones en
diferentes departamentos del interior de
grupos opositores que denuncian fraude y
rechazan
los resultados de estas elecciones
luízar se asume la presidencia con al
menos dos retos
uno de ellos sacar al país de la
profunda crisis en la que se encuentra y
por otro lado reconciliar a los
bolivianos que han quedado profundamente
divididos después de un año de
confrontación por otro lado les informo
que mañana regresa a bolivia el ex
presidente evo morales- team ha
permanecido refugiado en argentina casi
un año
para finalizar nos vamos a europa a esta
hora inicia en los sables d'olonne
lobont club la única vuelta al mundo en
barco que se realiza en solitario sin
escalas ni asistencias- la mítica
carrera se celebra desde 1989 allí está
nuestra corresponsal natalia ruiz
natalia buenos días cuéntanos más
detalles de esta competencia
muy buenos días pues ha habido una bruma
que se ha levantado en altamar y han
corrido la hora de comienzo de esta
carrera que estaba para la 102 minutos
ahora de francia esta vez será 40
minutos más tarde en ese momento en el
que estos treinta y tres capitanes seis
mujeres la primera vez que hay tantas
mujeres en competición pues partirán a
realizar esta vuelta al mundo son
cuarenta y cinco mil kilómetros ya lo
saben ustedes en solitario a bordo de
sus barcos sin distancia y pues espera
que lleguen entre enero y febrero el
récord a batir es de 74 días que
consiguió el francés a gemela
lo que hay hace cuatro años y es posible
que este año pueda vencer se este récord
porque los barcos vienen mucho más
rápidos con un los files unos apéndices
que van de cada lado del barco y que de
alguna manera permiten no solamente
ganar en velocidad sino casi como volar
un poco por encima del agua así que hay
posibilidades sobre todo por ejemplo
para el británico alex thomson uno de
los grandes favoritos y que en caso de
ganar se convertiría en el primer
ganador no francés de esta carrera en
esta novena edición que comienza el día
hoy estamos en confinamiento en francia
así que las personas que normalmente por
miles se llegan a despedir a los
diferentes a los navegantes cuando van a
subirse en sus barcos pues tuvieron que
hacerlo desde las ventanas y desde los
balcones de sus casas fue momentos muy
emotivos así que dentro de unos 40
minutos un poquito menos ya se espera
que comience esta gran vuelta al mundo y
pues ya sabremos en enero-febrero quién
ganará
natalia pues muchas gracias por todos
sus detalles y a ustedes gracias por
continuar con nosotros esto es france24
[Música]